Why are big pharma companies
paying billions of dollars
to take over, in some cases,
small companies that have just
one drug in their pipeline?
The answer is simple.
Drug companies want to
maximise the value of each drug
in their portfolio for as long
as possible until the patent
runs out.
But at some point, those
patents face a cliff.
The competition is waiting to
rush in and make generic drugs
to treat the same thing.
So what can drug companies do to
find the next blockbuster drug?
They can try to build
it in-house, or buy
the companies that hold the
promise of the next big drug.
But big pharma has
generally faced pressure
from its investors to
cut its own R&D spending.
That leaves big pharma
with a decision to make.
Do they risk buying a company
that has probably never
even brought a drug to
market, or do they wait?
The problem with waiting
is one of your competitors
may come and buy that company.
That is why, over
the last five years,
we have seen big pharma
making very big bets.
In 2015, AbbVie won a
three-way bidding war
to pay $21bn dollars to buy
Pharmacyclics, a cancer drug
maker that makes
literally one drug.
There was Pfizer's takeover
of Medication in 2016.
Also in 2016, AbbVie agreed to
pay $5.8bn to buy Stemcentrx.
This frenzy of
dealmaking led investors
to start wondering whether big
pharma was paying too much.
And that is why the
level of deal activity
dropped in 2017 and
for a lot of 2018,
but then things started
to pick right back up.
GlaxoSmithKline said it would
pay $5.1bn to buy Tesaro.
And Eli Lilly said it would
pay $8bn to buy Loxo Oncology.
And then, there was one of the
biggest deals in M&A history
across any asset class.
Bristol-Myers Squibb said
it was acquiring Celgene
in an eye-watering $90bn deal.
So are we set for
another big year
of pharmaceutical dealmaking?
That appears to be the
case, as big pharma looks
ready to take big risks again.